how are you softening some of the
screenwriters that you're working with
or maybe you're not that are either too
defensive or they're too mamby-pamby of
a yes person it is a balancing act so I
think that once writers start getting
notes and a lot of notes they they learn
they learn because you're gonna get
notes that are outright offensive to you
for what you've written but you learn to
take the good with the bad you you know
I always tell writers as they prepare
for the industry go find people who will
hate your work those are the people
whose notes you want you don't want the
people who tell you how brilliant you
are and how perfect it is you're not
gonna learn anything from that you're
gonna learn how to take notes from
getting notes that are really offensive
and finding something in there that you
can use what is the core of that what is
that what is the little kernel inside
that note that you can take and do
something with and really move the
material forward with then listen I
remember this from my days of being a
writer getting notes and just getting
infuriated and coming back and going
okay there was something there what is
that thing that's there what is the note
give are really saying so you want to
really teach writers to take notes to be
receptive to finding that kernel that
truth that is in every note or in most
notes you also want to work with writers
in the way that I work with writers is
not giving them the answers when they're
going okay so there's this note and I'm
gonna execute it that way is that good
no figure out your way to execute that
note and I get writers coming back to me
though there was one note that said this
how do i implement it you figure it out
you're on your own I'll sit with you and
I'll brainstorm with you once you have
the direction but it has to be your
direction and that's where you have to
listen to your inner writer right you
have to really foster your talent your
sensibilities of course it has to be
malleable you have to be able to work
with other people's sensibilities but
the key to being a great writer is
taking other people's ideas and making
them your own and falling just as in
love with them and being just as
invested in them as you would be had the
idea the concept originated with you
because the reality today is that you
know 2014 18
people WJ members made income in the
film industry roughly a hundred and
thirty-two script sold what does that
mean that means that over sixteen
hundred people made their money writing
pages doing writing assignments so how
do you become that writer who does
writing assignments assignments and does
it successfully you're able to take a
kernel of an idea and make it your own
and fall in love with it and really take
it and run with it in a way that makes
other people want to work with you
you